Today we'll be talking about one of the articles from our magazine, the benefits of pet ownership, by Jamie Moffatt.
We hope it's helpful!
Many people all over the world have pets and love them just as much, if not more, than their human companions.
Pets are known to provide a type of unconditional love that other humans can not always give.
Thus, humans tend to love their pets way more than their friends.
A key example of this is how dogs are constantly referred to as 'man's best friend.'
It can be extremely expensive to care for a pet. If you're doing it in the correct manner, anyway.
There are many things to account for when you have a pet, such as trips to the vet, food, toys, and all the necessary things for your pet's survival and comfort.
Having a pet is definitely not a thing to take lightly.
Through research, it can be proven that pet owners are more emotionally stable and physically active.
The act of walking your dog, alone, can cause these changes in a person.
Pet owners create a very special bond with their pet, both through walking and just living with them.
People with pets tend to be psychologically healthier because of the bond they have with their pet.
Animals can often help people get over or avoid the feeling of loneliness since they are a built-in best friend for their owners.
Our pets become our best confidant, our cuddle buddy when we're sad or when we need a good cuddle, and sometimes they are the one thing in our life we know we can count on at the end of the day.
You can gather very similar benefits to being a pet owner no matter what type of pet you own.
Animals provide an amount of emotional and social support that can be vital to a healthy mind and body.
This doesn't mean you should run out and buy a pet right away. If you're thinking about pet ownership, then these are simply some extra pluses for pet adoption.
Or, if you're having emotional struggles or constantly dealing with loneliness, you may want to look into getting a pet as they are helpful for those kind of things.
But if you're going to adopt a pet, do plenty of research and make sure you are ready for all the responsibilities that go along with having a pet.
Pets of all shapes and sizes provide a great amount of unconditional love and so much emotional and social support.
They will love you in a way unlike a person you will ever meet. This can be a great thing and can really help you if you're feeling down or like you're alone in the world.
Of course, they are not a solution to all problems, as the intensity of mental and emotional issues can vary.
However, having a pet is one of the many ways in which people can have happier and healthier lives.
If you enjoyed this video, be sure to subscribe to our channel and share with your friends.
You can buy our magazine from our store at iheartpsychology.myshopify.com
and you can support our Patreon at patreon.com/psych2gomagazine